Estás en un certamen de belleza en
directo, todo perfecto. Sonríes y de
repente se te caen todos los dientes.
Esto es lo que le ha pasado a una modelo
en Miss Gran Tailandia y el vídeo se ha
hecho viral en todo el mundo.
Pero en realidad no se le cayeron sus
dientes, se le cayó una prótesis dental
provisional. Y si analizamos bien el
vídeo, hay un detalle clave. Parece que
se ven dientes tallados, aunque también
podrían ser unos provisionales creados
para el evento que se ponen encima
simplemente y hacen el efecto de dientes
perfectos. Pero supongamos que son
provisionales. Eso, ¿qué significa? Que
probablemente estaba en medio de un
tratamiento con coronas, carillas o
puentes. Es decir, llevaba unos
provisionales. Los dientes provisionales
van cementados de forma temporal. No
están diseñados para aguantar fuerzas
intensas ni situaciones de estrés. son
una fase intermedia, pero si los tratas
como definitivos, mordiendo cosas duras,
pegajosas, etcétera, pueden
descementarse. Y eso fue precisamente lo
que ocurrió. Y esto, aunque impresiona
mucho, es algo bastante frecuente que
vemos en consulta. Los dientes
provisionales no están solo para salir
del paso, cumplen funciones clave
durante el tratamiento. Mantienen la
estética mientras se fabrica la prótesis
definitiva. Permiten masticar y hablar
con normalidad. Protegen los dientes
tallados y además sirven como una
herramienta fundamental para guiar la
encía y los tejidos blandos, definiendo
el resultado final en términos de forma
y perfil. Y muy importante, también
actúan como una prueba clínica, ya que
nos permiten evaluar la forma de la
mordida, la fonética y la estética antes
de colocar la restauración definitiva.
Por eso, si llevas provisionales, evita
morder fuerte, cuidado con alimentos
duros y sigue las indicaciones de tu
dentista.